neonicotinoids are the most widely used
insecticide in the world we know that
they have negative effects on bees
health from growth disorders reduced
efficiency in the immune system to
limiting the lifespan of the queen bee
it's been difficult to pin down sweeping
effects on bee populations but now
researchers have found more evidence for
another way neo Nick's effect bees by
contaminating their honey 198 honey
samples from around the world were
collected through a citizen science
project 75% of the samples tested
positive for neonicotinoids
contamination was prevalent all over the
world this confirms that these are
exposed to neonics in their food
researchers say the contamination is too
low to hurt humans consuming the honey
but that a significantly detrimental
effect on bees is likely what's more 45
percent of honey samples showed
contamination from multiple types of
units the combined effects of these
pesticides on bees is just starting to
be explored this global picture of
neonicotinoid contamination should be
useful to policymakers who are
considering the risks and benefits of
using the pesticides researchers hope
these findings will persuade authorities
to make publicly available data on neo
Nick usage then correlative studies can
be conducted to determine the
relationship between the use of these
pesticides and the current decline of
global bee populations
you
[Music]